o olá tudo bem gostaria de começar esse
tex com a seguinte reflexão
e quantas vezes ao dia o que você deseja
realizar não está totalmente alinhado
com as decisões que você toma já parou
para pensar nisso por exemplo você
deseja acordar mais cedo para ir para
academia mas no final decidi dormir mais
um pouco ou talvez você deseja antecipar
a entrega de um trabalho muito
importante que tem prazo mas perde a
motivação e acaba decidindo postergar
para o dia seguinte
e não mosca ver se você deseja controlar
a porção de comida mas não resisti e
decidi saciar a sua fome
é a melhor de todas você deseja evitar
aquele doce de sobremesa mas é tomado
por uma decisão aparentemente
incontrolável de comer aquele delicioso
pudim quem nunca não é mesmo enfim se a
vida é feita de escolhas o que nos faz
decidir escolher aquilo que é
incompatível com que realmente desejamos
[Música]
e eu vou mais além
se você saberia dizer quantas decisões
você toma durante um dia
é neste momento que você acorda até um
instante que você entra em sono profundo
ao final do dia por exemplo ao despertar
de manhã você tá na primeira decisão se
você vai se levantar ou se vai apertar o
botão soneca do despertador para dormir
mais cinco minutos você tem que tomar a
decisão de qual roupa vestir o que você
vai comer no café da manhã qualquer
caminho a seguir a trabalho e assim por
diante segue várias decisões ao dia
diferentes fontes de estudos comprovam
que uma pessoa adulta toma em média 35
mil decisões por dia bastante não é
mesmo se você é uma pessoa que dorme
pelo menos 8 horas por dia isto
significa que você toma uma decisão a
cada 1 segundo e meio mais ou menos ou
seja em um pis
o olhos você é capaz de tomar uma
decisão você já é deficiente ou
eficiente
o nitrato a maior parte dessas decisões
são tomadas de forma inconsciente e são
exatamente essas decisões que geram
reações incongruentes ao que realmente
desejamos mas sejam elas conscientes ou
inconscientes as nossas decisões saem um
padrão de causa-e-efeito pois cada
estímulo daquilo que eu vejo ou se sinto
gera uma decisão de escolha
eu vou dar um exemplo se eu assisto a um
trecho de um triste de um filme isto
pode me causar a decisão de emocionar ou
talvez se eu viro uma pessoa gritando
comigo é possível causar a decisão de me
aborrecer
e eu respondo a quando eu sinto uma
taquicardia isto pode causar a decisão
de criar uma certa ansiedade dependendo
da situação
[Música]
e perceba que o estímulo externo o mesmo
interno na forma de pensamentos e
memórias causa decisões conscientes ou
inconscientes
e portanto eu diria ter é possível
afirmar que a partir de pensamentos sou
capaz de decidir ativar sentimentos como
efeito desta causa e dessa forma usar
comportamentos que geram resultados
e para ser mais claro se eu pensar que
eu vou falhar e uma determinada situação
eu posso decidir sentir insegurança
o e consequentemente desbloquear a agir
como resultado realmente falharei
conquistar aquilo que eu desejava
é mas o inverso é verdadeiro se eu
pensar que eu posso acertar tecido
sentir confiança isso pode me levar a
realizar ação necessária para alcançar o
resultado desejado mas e quando eu sinto
que perdi o controle dos membros das
sociedades aqueles sentimentos que me
incomodam me bloqueio principalmente em
momentos desafiadores que desconhecido
nos influencia é certo que desejamos ter
confiança mais coragem nesses momentos
o porém para muitos de nós é
extremamente desafiador decidi pensar de
forma congruente adotar essas
comportamentos de coragem e confiança
não é mesmo
e eu vou dizer o seguinte né o ser
humano em sua evolução desde o homo
sapiens e possuem um instinto de
sobrevivência que está em constante
atividade para detectar os possíveis
riscos e ameaças
a paz quer pensamentos que tem o
significado de risco ameaça podem causar
o medo
[Música]
e receba então te existe uma intenção de
proteção e preservação por trás dos
medos ou quaisquer outros sentimentos
negativos que podem te bloquear
inclusive e deixar em um estado de
profunda inércia
e se existe uma intenção de proteção por
trás desse meses
ou será que devemos continuar brigando
contra eles não seria melhor acolher e
compreender os pensamentos de proteção
que causa x metros
e por exemplo se eu souber que o medo de
não saber o que vai acontecer amanhã tem
intenção de me proteger contra o perigo
do desconhecido talvez eu poderia
escolher aceitar que o medo existe por
um propósito e buscarem uma forma de
pensar em alternativas para as catar
essas hipóteses negativas ao invés de
apenas querer tentar controlar esse
sentimento que nos acomete negativamente
a outra forma de desviar dessas causas e
efeitos seria refletir em quais outros
contextos esses comportamentos
limitantes poderiam ser visto
e por exemplo se eu souber ansiedade tem
a intenção de preço por todas as
hipóteses de riscos e ameaças futuras
como seria se utilizasse esta mesma
estratégia de pensamento para calcular
riscos de execução de um projeto de um
trabalho tenho certeza que seria muito
mais útil ter uma imaginação abundante
para planejar no trabalho
no entanto só é possível promover esta
mudança de comportamento ser em primeiro
lugar você estiver para disposto a gerar
esta transformação segundo isso
realmente for importante para você
e finalmente definitivamente é claro o
sentido do propósito de sair da inércia
para isso é fundamental acertar acolher
essas vulnerabilidades para poder
tratá-las e evitar que se tornem
controlados afinal de contas o que
adianta a pensar em uma solução se não
conhecemos o problema
e além disso para encontrar um ponto de
equilíbrio dessas causas e efeitos de
decisões que tomamos as quais são de
nossa exclusiva responsabilidade é
necessário dedicar mais atenção a nós
mesmos
há muitos as causas efeitos referem-se a
como interpretamos o que os outros
desejam ou nos julgam e acabamos tomando
decisões para satisfazer essas
percepções do mundo esquecendo daquela
pessoa mais importante para nós
é nós mesmo sem querer alimentar
qualquer sentimento de egocentrismo mas
compreendendo a importância eu falou de
cuidar de nós mesmos talvez alguns de
nós pode exigir uma coragem para dar
esse devido valor mas tenho certeza que
quanto mais praticado melhor você poderá
sentir como causa e efeito de novas
decisões mas é seu tipo
eu posso afirmar que todos nós temos
todos os recursos necessários para nossa
vida basta você olhar para trás no seu
passado e recordar os momentos de
conquistas pequenos ou grandes mas que
você viveu e partir da sua própria
atitude se mesmo assim ainda tiver
dificuldade de refletir sobre essas
modernidades saiba aqui levantar a mão
para pedir ajuda certamente poderá
atender a mesma intenção de te proteger
assim como os meses e ansiedade também
promove mas quais dessas decisões vocês
cobre a partir de agora
olá eu sou verdadeiramente grato pela
oportunidade de contribuir com o meu
conhecimento e poder conferir com a
minha missão em fazer o bem e ajudar as
pessoas para alcançar a plenitude fiquem
com deus que todos estejam seguros
saudáveis e cuidem-se gratidão
e aí